judging by the incredible amount of hype
surrounding zack snyder's justice league
it would be easy to assume that upon its
debut on hbo max the massive movie was
destined for one of two fates
either it would turn out to be a massive
flop essentially dooming all future fan
campaigns
or it would become a resounding success
that sets a tantalizing precedent so
which one is it shaping out to be
right now the scales are tipping toward
b it's still just a wee bit too early to
get a full read on the situation but it
certainly looks like business is booming
for hbo max
not only have critics had plenty of good
things to say about the snyder cuts but
fans are loving the movie to the point
that their love reportedly caused the
streaming platform to crash
let's take a look at how zack snyder's
justice league sent hbo max crashing
down
when hbo max released zack snyder's
justice league on thursday march 18
2021 people were ready so ready in fact
that the streaming service experienced a
massive tsunami of eager viewers right
away
while lots of customers is generally
perceived as a great thing the sheer
volume of this particular viewer spike
reportedly caused
parts of hbo max to collapse under the
sheer weight to pent up snyder burst
demand
hbo asia seems to have taken the worst
of it in response to widespread outages
the official hbo asia twitter account
tweeted hi
everyone we are working hard to restore
the service sorry to keep you waiting
but thank you for your patience
as the replies to this message made
clear the people who remember have been
waiting for years to see the movie were
not exactly amused
especially as some users reported that
the crash lasted for several hours
no god no
god please no no no
one snyder fan tweeted how we've been
waiting for three hours
another exasperated twitter user chimed
in complete with a crying emoji
it's still not working come on i've been
waiting for so long
one would think zack snyder fans would
have learned that patience is a virtue
at this point on the day the movie
dropped the issues with hbo max
reportedly started around 2am
eastern and in under 9 hours the down
detector tracking site received no less
than 127 outage reports about the
streamer
according to the site's data things
remain somewhat problematic for the rest
of the day
with the biggest outage spike hitting
just before 7 pm 119 reports
reports continued to flood in until 11
pm suggesting this was not just a
temporary
issue the situation started to calm down
around midnight and by the wee hours of
march 19th everything seemed to be back
to normal across the network
regardless of what exactly caused the
problem the spike was pretty substantial
since hbo asia actually addressed it
for context when game of thrones season
8 premiered in 2019 and folks took to
social media with similar outage issues
hbo specifically told entertainment
weekly that it didn't quote
experience any service outages on hbo go
or hbo now in the us during
last night's game of thrones season 8
premiere does this mean that zack
snyder's justice league blew the
premiere of game of thrones final season
out of the water
the final numbers remain to be seen but
the fact that zack snyder's justice
league's release coincided with so many
reported issues on hbo max sure seems to
speak
volumes of the project's popularity at
the moment all indications are that this
precedent setting experiment in
revisionist filmmaking has been a
resounding success
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite dc eu movies are coming
soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one